a desk with mom and dad's laptop this is
where or zeny and Inasa
Janos II may spend as much as six hours
a day they have a passion for
programming a skill they taught
themselves by getting onto the Internet
it started last year and I had a really
small phone at the time so I'm Google
Chrome wasn't really functional for me
so it says great something I could work
for myself so research start the browser
when he said once buildin your brothers
for himself I thought that'd be cool say
kind of tag along an alien food they
call their app the crocodile browser it
uses very little bandwidth and almost
60,000 people have already downloaded it
that's a strong incentive for an AC and
Orsini to keep improving their product
the boy's mother is proud but she's
insistent that they need to slow down
and pay attention to the rest of life we
have to plan this graph to balance its
you press L for programming great time
for schoolwork you know you're still in
school you must finish school
the two are using the school holidays to
do an internship at talent accelerator
an educational startup in Lagos they can
continue developing their project here
they benefit from the experience of
other programmers and IT entrepreneurs
they've received lots of encouragement
from the program where counselors see
great promise in the brothers this guys
are two wonderful young people who have
shown some level of brilliance what
they've done with a crocodile light
browser and yes it's not perfect yet was
a very nice idea and I believe as
potential the two young interns have
learned that user feedback is the key to
improving their browser and si and asana
have already received plenty of
motivation along with concrete ideas for
additional features I want it to be like
on every like something I put it every
day like a necessity for people
like we can't do it can't do anything
sizing Google asked me like that
when the brothers would be as popular as
any mainstream product you use on your
phone like you said you use Google Maps
if he wanted to be that popular NAC is
going back to South Africa where he'll
finish school by a smartphone and laptop
the two brothers will continue to pursue
their IT career together over the
Internet